all revolutions have to start somewhere
and in golf it might just be here on the
fairways outside some albums
the big bold promises of this breakaway
are pretty simple
louder faster more exciting golf
but it's bankrolled by extraordinary
amounts of money from saudi arabia's
investment fund
and that's the rub on these greens for
those that have signed up
anywhere in the world you wouldn't play
if vladimir putin had a tournament
would you play that
that's speculation not even going to
comment on speculation
well you're just asking us to answer a
hypothetical question there which well
the moral questions
six-time major winner phil mickelson
faced the same awkward moments having
previously said the saudis were scary
he's now signed up to secure his
family's future
i understand that
many people have very strong opinions
and may disagree with my decision
and i can empathize with that
at this time
this is uh an opportunity that gives me
a chance to have
the most balance uh in my life uh going
forward and i think this is going to do
a lot of good for the game
precisely how it will help grassroots
golf isn't immediately clear
the bottom line here is that the players
are playing because the money on offer
is just too much to resist the moral
maze is just something they'll find a
way through
and it's amazed more players are willing
to try and work out
the american big hitter bryson de
chambeau is one of the latest to sign up
having previously said he would stick
with the established pga tour sometimes
you need a different format things to
spice things up but at the end of the
day the us open the masters the british
open they're the ones where
the fact the fans really get behind them
and they get really enthusiastic about
that event and you know who doesn't want
to see them lift the claret joe go put
the green jacket on there's just so much
history in that the ambition of live
golf is clear tiger woods was offered a
fee reportedly approaching a billion
dollars which he turned down plenty of
others who would tee off here in anger
tomorrow found that what was on offer to
them
was impossible to resist
tom parmenter sky news saint albans